voici le moment pour essayer les petits
souliers rose dans les années 60 elle a
nourri la jeunesse canadienne de contes
et de fantaisie sous les traits de
fanfreluches son personnage de grand
mère dans passe partout aussi bercé
l'enfance d'autres générations
j'avais dix ans je l'aidais à moscou
avec ma grand mère
j'étais bien à 91 ans kenny à rechercher
callas se livre avec toute la candeur et
l'humour qu'on lui connaît et raconte
son extraordinaire périple qui l'a mené
de la russie jusqu'à montréal en 1934
pour aller vivre chez son oncle et sa
tante après que sa grand-mère soit
tombée malade
ainsi pour un grand les flaques d'eau
pour attraper le train pour londres
les semelles de mes souliers neufs sont
mes à décoller
quand on est arrivé à londres mais
souliers baillet à grande gueule c'est
mon père et ça aussi c'est mon père
aimait ça c'est mon sens c'est la petite
kim
oui mais là il est plus petit elle a 6
ans chez elle au milieu de livres russe
les photos de sa famille ont une place
de choix jamais elle n'avait pensé
raconté en public son parcours rempli
d'anecdotes cocasses
jusqu'à ce qu'un journaliste de radio
canada lui en parle l'an passé c'était
un voyage démarre à cambrai losc et j'ai
commencé à y penser
malgré moi et j'ai eu envie de raconter
parce que c est quelque chose d habitude
la petite qui m'a même passé un week-end
en détention à son arrivée au canada en
raison d'un changement d'itinéraire non
annoncé nous prenions nos repas avec les
autres détenus
assis autour d'une grande table je ne
connais pas la rencontre je ne connais
pas les plats au menu et vous êtes
retourné des genres si oui je suis
retourné une fois oui mais non c'était
pas la russie que j'avais quitté comme
je suis retourné en russie c'était parce
que je pensais c'est mon pays plus
qu'ici mais quand j'étais là j'ai
réalisé que c'est ici ma vie vraiment
l'unique représentation de son compte
personnel a eu lieu à guichets fermés en
février les spectateurs en sont sortis
charme et c'est un gramme
on nous a migré non seulement des
histoires de sa vie mais elle les a
livrés avec un art magnifique qui est le
sien
c'est une conteuse c'est vraiment une
écrivaine proposent non je ne je ne suis
pas content non j'ai du mal à mettre ce
mot là parce que j'ai entendu les vrais
compteur c'est quand un québécois qui
qui ont elles modèle terroir qui
tellement riche tellement bon et drôle
et profonde est familier
moi j'ai pas ça à 91 ans kim
yaroshevskaya aurait voulu retourner sur
scène en avril pour raconter son voyage
en amérique à nouveau mais sa santé en a
malheureusement décidé autrement